Dylan we did not get to see enough of
Dylan in Bachelorette I have heard you
are the most sought-after man in
Paradise who's the most sought-after guy
in Paradise Dylan and who's the most
sought-after lady Hanna I wouldn't say
the most sought-after I listen I'm
excited for paradise I think it's gonna
be a great time your eyes really lit up
just then how serious do things get for
you in paradise
[Laughter]
hopefully things get really serious in
paradise I'm uh
listen I think it's gonna be an
unbelievable experience I think
everybody's gonna get to see something
of me and a part of me that not
everybody does get to see I also just
heard that Hannah G is the most
sought-after lady in paradise would you
agree Hannah she's unbelievable
I mean I she's obviously just beautiful
and I think it's unfortunate we didn't
see her personality and I'm excited to
just I'm excited for everyone to see
kind of what Hannah G is like that's so
interesting it's like you didn't get
enough air time in Bachelorette and
Hannah G didn't get seen enough on
bachelor and you're both the most sought
after people in paradise according to
Demi that's really interesting it seems
like a match made in heaven
Demi said I was my Sonicare does that
mean no I
what are you intern Hannah G or Demi I
find you very attractive can't stop
smiling right now can't stop smiling but
I listen I think there's a lot of
attractive women in the world and the
most important thing is just like an
emotional and mental and obviously a
physical attraction to it - paradise
paradise is it's great for some it is
terrible for others and I'm just hoping
that the people that's not so great for
her they have the opportunity to lift
themselves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]